[Music]  right what do you need to know this is  my boyfriend  jason he's great i mean his hair's  better longer but  i'll go shirts is that right so  turns out we can't have kids the fun way  which is you know it's absolutely  completely totally  fine so what do we do now a small piece  of us dies and we just  carry on with whatever's left all right  well as long as we've got a plan  but we have a plan we're gonna adopt our  own family and i thought right  if we are gonna do this we need to  become more you know  grown up start using bay leaves in  cooking even though they don't taste of  anything and everyone knows it  you're talking like an american again  you never hate it when you do that for  them  sort of realized you never really feel  grown up already enough for the big  stuff do you  you just have to sort of do it anyway or  you run out of time  so that's what we're doing we're doing  it anyway let's see what happens shall  we  you